mexico and the usa played their seventh
final at the ali y jane stadium on
sunday just like in 2007 the usa
beat trick and was crowned champion in this
edition of the gold cup it is important to
mention that the concacaf tournament
began in the 60s  used to
call the concacaf nations cup and
it was not until 1991 that it became
what we all know as the gold cup
thus changing the format of the
competition let's see a summary of the
usa gold cup championships during
the final on sunday first of  august
the stars and stripes team
got their seventh title after
beating mexico by the slightest difference in
overtime in 2017 the usa beat
jamaica 2-1 while in 2013 the
usa beat panama by a score of
1-1  0
7 it was the first time that the
american team won the
concacaf classic in this tournament after a score
of 2 to 1 with goals from landon donovan and
benny feilhaber in 2005 they did it
against panama in a round  of penalties since
the score would have remained 0 to 0 the
usa would achieve its second championship
in 2002 against costa rica after a
result of 2 to 0 while it would
consecrate the gold cup champion for the first time
in 1991 after defeating
honduras in  penalties 4 to 3 congratulations to the
usa for their seventh gold cup title
natalia lancellotti reported for them swimming in spanish